well I'll give this little cookie an  hour before we're doing the no-pants  dance time to musk up Wow blood in point  of actual fact all I really want to do  is have intercourse with you as soon as  possible just let me know  hi I was hoping you'd say that  I just got out of the shower yeah  can I borrow your towel protect my car  just hit a water buffalo my favorite  color is like my favorite animal is  puppies I like serving the Lord hide him  play volleyball you gotta be kidding me  everything you just said it's my  favorite thing to do every day I  guarantee you this you're never gonna  regret going home with a guy from the  bar that one time it was a total Tomcat  in the sack but I can't guarantee that  you won't not regret it no the double  negative you're a double negative you  know what it's time to go home really no  it's for woody but okay I'll do it if  you don't solve three so should I get my  car yours can I pull the car around  have you been drinking  [Music]